buon pomeriggio a tutti bello vivere in
montagna
a me piace sarà a causa delle mie radici
trentine ma io ho un debole per
l'ambiente di montagna io penso che dire
in una città come trento contornata da
montagne o anche vide una qualsiasi
città o paese di montagna cda tante
sicurezze dal punto di vista della
qualità dell'ambiente della qualità
naturale ad esempio la sicurezza di
poter respirare aria aria pulita o la
sicurezza di poter bere acqua pulita ma
anche altre sicurezze del tipo potersi
gustare un bel tramonto sulle montagne
nel mini corso della vita quotidiana o
potersi fare una bella sciata quando noi
sentiamo l'esigenza ma non è mica tutto
oro quello che luccica
guardate un po quello che ci può
capitare
vivere in montagna implica anche qualche
pericolo e quando la natura si scatena
ci prende alla sprovvista
come nel caso del sindaco di baselga di
pinè nell'agosto del 2010
siamo due mesi dalle sue prime elezioni
sindaco novello una bimba che sta per
nascere
questione di giorni forse di ore la sera
della vigilia di ferragosto piove ma è
una giornata piace una serata piacevole
a teatro arriva una telefonata c'è
qualcosa che qualche problema ma sembra
tutto sotto controllo
il sindaco spegne il telefono per non
disturbare e lo lascia spento la scelta
la serata si conclude il sindaco va a
dormire ma il sindaco non sa quello che
sta per succedere non sa quello che sta
succedendo
la natura si sta scatenando incurante
del sonno delle persone
incurante del fatto che il nostro
novello sindaco può essere può avere
un'esperienza può essere non avere
esperienza a gestire situazioni di
emergenza alle 5 30 del mattino
piove sempre di più una colata scenda
dalla val molinara e colpisce l'abitato
di campolongo alle 5 30 un campanello
sveglio di soprassalto il sindaco per
lui comincia una settimana d'inferno e
per più di altre cento persone
quell'inferno è già cominciato ci sono
stati danni ci sono stati sicuramente
molti molti disguidi ma non ci sono
state vittime
quindi possiamo un po raccontare questa
storia con una certa leggerezza ma
purtroppo non succede sempre così dimaro
30 ottobre 2018 altra colata di detriti
questa volta la colata direttrici degli
attriti colpisce il campeggio e lo
spazza via
per fortuna quel che peggio era chiuso
da qualche giorno altrimenti sarebbe
stato strage però colpisce anche una
serie di case una donna rimane
intrappolata nella sua abitazione ed è
tragedia lascia un marito e due bambini
ma cos'è una colata di detriti
quando succede perché succede perché
così ha un potenziale distruttivo così
elevato immaginate una montagna con un
versante e consideriamo il suo bacino di
raccolta di scolo sul su un torrente
quando piove normalmente come oggi
l'acqua viene raccolta viene raccolta
dal torrente portata verso valle
il torrente trasporta qualche sedimento
un po di sabbia un po di ghiaia e
qualche ciotola ma sostanzialmente non
succede nulla se però le piogge sono
particolarmente intense e in quel bacino
ci sono degli accumuli di sedimenti beh
questi sedimenti si possono mettere in
movimento si forma un miscuglio di acqua
e sedimenti che si muove verso valle
anche abbastanza con con grande velocità
arriva nel fondovalle dove la pendenza
diventa molto più piccola tutto il
materiale solido si deposita l'alveo si
riempie la colata di detriti esce dal
suo alveo e combina i guai che abbiamo
appena visto la cosa abbastanza
impressionante e delle colate di detriti
è che questa miscuglio di acqua e
sedimenti si comporta come fosse un
fluido e immaginate che la percentuale
di solido in questo fluido può essere
più del 60 per cento e nonostante questo
si comporta come un liquido certamente
un liquido un po particolare è un
liquido molto pesante e proprio per
questo suo peso e ha una potenza
distruttiva incredibile guardate cosa
combina con queste case una colata
arriva sul finire e lo spazza via
arriva anche sulla casa la casa un po
più robusta resiste un po di più
sì certo ma dopo un po si porta via
anche la casa certamente e le colate gli
attriti e non sono gli unici pericoli
naturali che si possono incontrare in
montagna le colate di detriti sono uno
di quelli che vengono chiamati i
pericoli idrogeologici
i pericoli idrogeologici sono i pericoli
che sono causati da fenomeni che come
dice il nome sono un interrelazione tra
libro cioè l'acqua e geo
la terra oltre le colate di detriti e
abbiamo anche le esondazioni di fiumi ed
i torrenti nel caso delle fondazioni
prevale l'acqua sui sedimenti mentre
nelle valanghe anche nel valanghe
prevale l'acqua ma l'acqua in questo
caso è e allo stato solido e poi abbiamo
anche le frane nelle frane prevale la
parte geo cioè i sedimenti rispetto
all'acqua infatti le frane si muovono
una maniera abbastanza particolare
diversa da tutti gli altri pericoli
idrogeologici
certamente le colate detriti e in parte
le valanghe sono i pericoli
idrogeologici che generano più danno e
più vittime come facciamo a parlare di
sicurezza nei confronti dei pericoli
idrogeologici
beh il primo la prima parola chiave è
previsione maree previsione di un
pericolo idrogeologico non è come fare
le previsioni del tempo è per tanti
aspetti molto più complicato è
sicuramente molto meno certo e fare
previsione nel campo idrogeologico vuol
dire innanzitutto ed essenzialmente
produrre delle mappe del pericolo
queste mappe individuano le zone di
territorio che possono essere soggetti a
pericoli idrogeologici e le mappe
indicano anche il livello di pericolo
che può essersi alto medio o basso ma
cosa vuol dire pericolo alto medio e
basso
in altre parole come si misura come si
fa a misurare il pericolo non è mica
facile misurare il pericolo perché il
pericolo non è una caratteristica del
fenomeno fisico che gene che lo genera e
non si capisce con questo esempio
vogliamo capire il pericolo generato su
una persona dall'impatto di un oggetto
beh noi di questo di questo fenomeno
possiamo studiare bene
l'intensità
dell'impatto è una caratteristica fisica
per l'intensità dell'impatto
semplificando un po e dipende dalla
massa da quanto è grande e l'oggetto che
va a impattare e dalla velocità che
l'oggetto a quando impatta sulla persona
ma se il pericolo
dipendesse da queste due quantità allora
dovrei dire che il pericolo di impatto
più grosso che mi possa capitare è il
pericolo dovuta a un meteorite meteorite
a grande massa grande velocità quindi
pericolo grandissimo però se pensate ad
un bambino che va a scuola la mattina i
suoi genitori non gli dicono mica
attento ai meteoriti gli dicono stai
attento alle macchine mentre attraversi
la strada ma le macchine hanno meno
velocità e hanno meno massa perché
dunque hanno più pericolo è perché il
pericolo nella nostra mente è una
percezione che mette insieme e
l'intensità di un fenomeno ma anche la
sua possibilità che questo accada
quindi intensità e probabilità mettendo
insieme queste due cose possiamo
definire il pericolo e le nostre mappe
del pericolo cercano di fare questo
darci un'idea di questo livello del
pericolo probabilità il tempo di ritorno
si perchè in campo idrogeologico più che
parlare di probabilità si usa un altra
grandezza che è il tempo di ritorno che
stretta parente della probabilità
ma è un po più è un po più semplice da
capire il tempo di ritorno di un evento
non di un evento estremo è il tempo
medio che intercorre perché l'evento si
riproponga si ripresenti compagna di
nuovo con delle caratteristiche simili e
sottolineo tempo medio bene questo
concetto è molto volte espresso in
maniera non opportuna sui giornali mi
sono un paio di titolo che ho preso da
un paio di giornali vediamo il primo
maltempo per gli esperti eventi così
accadono una volta ogni 50 anni
letta così sembrerebbe che un evento
capita oggi fra 50 anni e poi
regolarmente ogni 50 anni
per cui si è capitato oggi fra 50 anni
sono super 50 anni e sono sicuro falsa
sicurezza quei 50 anni sono un tempo di
ritorno un tempo medio per cui se oggi
succede un evento il successivo può
succedere fra vent'anni e quello dopo
fra 80 anni la media e 50 anni
però fra 20 anni può ricapitarmi non 50
anni quindi attenzione poi vedete 50
anni 500 anni i tempi di ritorno possono
essere molto diversi tempi di ritorno
elevati ad esempio 500 anni stanno
indicare fenomeni molto rari ma molto
molto intensi tempi di ritorno piuttosto
bassi 50 anni indicano fenomeni più
frequenti ma di intensità un po più
piccola bene serve un altro elemento un
altro strumento per produrre con le
mappe del pericolo che abbiamo visto
prima che è un simulatore di colate
detritiche questo il mio campo di
ricerca non è facile fare un simulatore
di colate di detriti e per certi aspetti
è più facile fare un simulatore di volo
per un aereo che non un simulatore di
colate tra parentesi quella che vedete è
la simulazione della colata della val
molinara quella che abbiamo visto prima
perché è difficile simulare una colata
di detriti perché ancora non sappiamo
descrivere in maniera accurata quello
che succede dal punto di vista fisico e
dal punto di vista matematico quindi
fare una simulazione fanno un simulatore
di colate è ancora una bella sfida per
il mondo scientifico
passiamo al secondo elemento alla
seconda parola chiave prevenzione cosa
vuol dire prevenzione prevenzione vuol
dire evitare che un fenomeno
idrogeologico produca dei danni
allora come possiamo impedire la
produzione di danni
la prima cosa che possiamo fare è usare
quelle mappe che abbiamo
questo prima e limitare l'uso del
territorio in modo tale che se dovesse
succedere un pericolo idrogeologico
questo non crea danni
ad esempio se nelle zona pericolo
elevato
impediamo di costruire se arriva una
colata in quel punto dove non ci sono
case non ci sono persone ben honda non
fa danni quindi siamo tranquilli quindi
l'uso del territorio può essere limitato
da questi da questo sistema
c'è un altro modo che possiamo un altro
strumento che possiamo mettere in piedi
per la prevenzione
potremmo mettere in piedi un sistema di
allerta un sistema che ci avverte quando
sta per capitare qualche cosa purtroppo
con i pericoli idrogeologici con le
colate ma anche con le con le valanghe e
questi sistemi funzionano ancora poco
non siamo ancora in grado di fare una
buona umbro un sistema di allerta
quello che invece riusciamo a fare è
fare delle opere e nel caso di colate
detritiche le cose che si fanno sono
queste cose qui che si chiamano briglie
queste sono le briglie fessure che sono
proprio specifiche per le colate di
detriti a sinistra vedete la fotografia
di stada valle cia dal davanti della
briglia a destra vedete il dietro quello
verso la montagna è questo questi
sistemi sono fatti in modo tale per cui
quando arriva la colata il materiale
solido viene intrappolato in questa
vasca in questo grosso bacino di
raccolta che c'è a monte della briglia
mentre l'acqua esce dalle fessure e
quindi si scinde la fase solida da
quella liquida fermando la fase solida
si impedisce che a valle della briglia
si possono generare quei danni che
abbiamo visto prima
ma arriviamo all'ultima parola chiave
che è la protezione sicuramente è
un'illusione pensare di riuscire a
prevenire ogni fenomeno idrogeologico è
impossibile quindi qualche volta ci
capiterà allora quanto ca quando capita
noi abbiamo bisogno di un sistema
efficiente che riesca a portare dei
soccorsi nelle zone colpite
quindi una buona organizzazione ma per
avere una buona organizzazione
bisogna avere anche dei buoni piani di
protezione civile dei piani che
prevedano cosa fare e come fare beh su
questo possiamo stare sicuri è la nostra
la nostra protezione civile a una dei
migliori al mondo per cui su questo
siamo sicuri però tutto il sistema di
organizzazione non è sufficiente abbiamo
bisogno di autoprotezione
come abbiamo visto prima quando abbiamo
visto cosa dobbiamo fare e quando
dobbiamo lasciare in sicurezza questa
sala dove sono le uscite di emergenza
bene dovremo riuscire a conoscere cosa
si fa anche quando succedono pericoli di
questo genere
quindi serve informazione e formazione
la maggior parte delle volte in pericolo
idrogeologico si è trasformato in
tragedia proprio perché le persone non
si sono comportate in maniera adeguata
non hanno fatto delle cose sbagliate
bene quindi in definitiva è bello vivere
in montagna si certamente
io penso che si possa vivere anche con
una buona sicurezza non al cento per
cento non a 360 gradi ma con una buona
sicurezza
se mettiamo in piedi delle opere di
delle attivita di previsione di
prevenzione e di protezione grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]